So, I want to show you a very special item
here.
This right here to my left is an authentic
New York Yankees stadium seat, the house,
where Ruth built and we all know this logo
here, the New York Yankees.
I just want you to think about this.
I had to buy this because I'm planning on
giving this to one of our top performers in
our company.
And the reason why I'm showing this to you
is because I just want you to think about
the stories behind this seat.
Who sat in this chair?
I mean, this was there for 100 years, 80 years,
90 years, how many fans sat here and watched
Babe Ruth hit a home run?
Or Mickey Mantle?
Or Roger Maris?
Who knows what stories, how much beer has
been spilled on this or hotdog ketchup or fights
and disappointments and ninth inning full
count home runs, you lose, you win, world
series.
. . It doesn't matter what it is.
When I see this, this just came in today,
when I see this, to me, it represents a lot
of history.
But if you're looking at this from the business
standpoint, this to me represents a brand
that was backed up by an entrepreneur CEO
who was willing to self-promote this brand
that is known as the #1 brand in the world.
This is the most recognized sports brand in
the world, because they know how to self-promote.
And by the way, this brand has 26 or 27 world
series championships, and this brand, is worth,
if you wanted to buy it, $3.4 billion.
You know why?
Because an entrepreneur knew how to promote
this brand way before anybody else thought
of the Yankees as the greatest sports organization
in major league baseball.
Some would even say any sport you think about,
you think about the Yankees.
Why am I starting this video this way?
Well, first of all, I'm a big baseball guy
and items like this fascinate me.
Right now, I'm in negotiation with somebody
that owns a 1952 Mickey Mantle high graded,
we're talking high numbers, we're not talking
$100,000 card, we're talking a pretty expensive
card.
I'm a fan of sports teams like this who self-promote.
And I think you as an entrepreneur need to
figure out a way to self-promote your business.
And in today's video I'm going to explain
it in a way that, especially to people who
are.
. . because if you're cocky, and you're way,
way too cocky, maybe your approach needs to
be different on how you self-promote.
But I think this message is more for the people
who are uncomfortable on how to self-promote
yourself and your business.
And I'm going to tell you, not only is it
costing you business, not only is it costing
you profit, it's hurting everybody in your
company if you yourself don't figure out the
proper way of self-promoting what you already
believe in, whether it's yourself, your business,
your people, your clients, your product, your
vendors, your industry.
. . it doesn't matter.
Someone behind this brand, the New York Yankees
knew how to do it.
So, I'm going to cover with you many different
examples, and I'll give you do's and don'ts,
something you can implement right off the
bat for you to start self-promoting.
So before I get into it, I want you to see
a number here.
I got four names here to my left.
These are four candidates, that one of them
is going to be the president in the next few
days.
I think by the time you watch this video,
the video will be launched on election day.
This video is being launched on election day.
By the time this video is done with, the first
day it comes out, we have a new president
in America.
It's either going to be Trump, Clinton, Johnson,
Stein.
So many people now watching this, you already
know who the president is.
But this is the point I want to make to you
here.
Watch this number here.
If I asked you who Jill Stein is, I am willing
to bet 90% of you have no idea who Jill Stein
is.
If I asked you who Gary Johnson is, I'm willing
to bet 80% of you have no idea who Gary Johnson
is.
If I was to ask you, do you know who Hillary
Clinton or Trump is, I'm willing to bet that
99.99999% of you know who Clinton and Trump
is.
Do you know why?
Because these two know how to self-promote,
these two [Johnson and Stein] don't know how
to self-promote.
It doesn't mean their argument isn't strong.
It just means they're terrible at self-promotion.
Let me give you some stats here for you to
be thinking about.
Jill Stein has 261,000 followers on Twitter.
Gary Johnson, Libertarian, she [Jill Stein]
represents the Green Party, and you notice
it's green, Gary Johnson is yellow, Libertarian.
He's got 397,000 followers on Twitter.
She [Hillary] has 10.1 million, Trump's got
12.9 million Twitter followers.
Brand wise, he's [Trump] by far the best self-promoter
in the marketplace.
Obviously, you see the Trump brand all over
the place - whether you like him or not, there's
a lot to be learned from anybody.
Because on the complete opposite side here,
Ali who Sports Illustrated said, the greatest
athlete of the last century, he said, "I'm
the greatest."
And he came out saying it when he didn't believe
it.
And then he delivered.
And then he became the greatest, Ali, right.
We just lost him this past year.
You think about TBE, The Best Ever, Mayweather,
The Money Team.
I'm the best ever.
So many people hate Mayweather!
So many people love Mayweather.
The reality is he never lost.
I'm not a Mayweather fan.
Many of you know if you follow me, but guess
what?
The guy was undefeated, he called himself
the best ever and I think the last fight he
had with Pacquiao, what was it, a $200 million,
how much money did you make on that fight.
Think about that for a moment here.
Jordan on this side.
The greatest of all time.
Primetime, Deion Sanders, #21.
You know, when he said there's nobody, I don't
care what position, Dennis was telling me,
if you tell me any position, quarterback,
whatever, there will never ever be a better
quarterback as good as me because I'm the
best ever, #21.
You look at more brands - Cowboys, $4 billion
company.
The most expensive sports franchise in the
world is Cowboys.
Then you have Barcelona Real Madrid, then
you have the Yankees here.
Nike, self-promotion.
Apple, self-promotion.
These are people who know how to promote their
brand and today they're learning how to promote
themselves.
So if you, if you yourself don't make a decision
from watching this video how to self-promote
yourself and how to self-promote your brand,
I guarantee you, you will be left behind.
So let's go through a couple different points
here on thinking about self-promotion and
how not to do it and how to do it.
By the way, just think about it for a moment
here, with even LeBron James.
For the longest time, LeBron James didn't
want to answer one question.
What's the question?
The question was Hey, are you better than
Michael Jordan?
He would always say what?
He would say, "Oh, you know, Mike's the greatest
of all time, why would you even ask the question?"
You know, why would you even ask the question?
And do you know what he started saying this
here?
What did he start saying this in an interview?
Do you know what he said?
I'm chasing the what?
The ghost.
I'm chasing the ghost.
Who's the ghost?
Michael Jordan.
Why?
Because Michael Jordan's the greatest of all
time.
And LeBron wants to say what?
Guess what?
I think I may be the greatest of all time.
I've been to seven or eight, and he's only
been to six.
Yes, he won six for six, but I never had a
Pippen of a Horace Grant.
He's making an argument.
I make everybody else stronger.
And Jordan was himself.
All of those stats, he's putting up to say
he's the greatest of all time.
And by the way, do I think he's going to be
the greatest of all time?
I don't think he will be the greatest of all
time.
But you know what I do like?
I love the fact that he said it.
Finally, he said it.
Kobe said it and he put himself on the line.
You've got to be able to have the audacity
to say it as well.
But there's certain things you got to do before
you say it.
So keep in mind, let's identify something
before I get into my 11 points.
What is the difference between self-promotion
and bull shitting?
and bullshitting?
Self-promotion can be backed up.
Bullshitters can't back up.
Big difference.
So a lot of the introverts who don't like
to self-promote because they're like, "Man,
I don't want to come across as a bullshitter,"
if you know what you're doing, don't worry
about it.
Self- promote, if you know how to deliver.
Don't worry about it.
And I'll give you a formula today on how to
do it so you're not going to feel uncomfortable
about how to go out there and self-promote
yourself.
You know, this whole statement that we hear
about fake it till you make it, fake it till
you make it, we hear it all the time, fake
it till you make it.
Well, yes, fake it till you make it, but you
better know what the hell you're doing while
you're on the way of faking it till you make
it, because if you don't know what you're
doing, you're just fake, period.
You're just fake, period.
The whole act as if, you can act as if, but
you better know what you're doing while you're
acting as if.
There's got to be a part of you that knows
what you're doing.
So, how do you self-promote yourself?
Rule #1: You've got to be shameless about
self-promoting yourself.
You've got to be shameless about self-promoting
yourself.
You can't be uncomfortable when you're self-promoting
You've got to be shameless.
I guarantee you, Deion's shameless.
Ali's shameless, Mayweather's shameless, Steinbrenner,
Yankees, he was one of the recent owners who
passed away and passed it over to his son,
shameless.
Apple's shameless.
Nike, Phil Knight, shameless, Cowboys, Jerry
Jones, shameless.
Trump shameless.
Clinton shameless.
[Johnson Stein] a little shyer, but they're
still more shameless than the rest of the
people in the world.
You've got to be shameless.
If you're not shameless, no one is going to
know who you are.
And a part of why we don't want to be shameless
is because we're embarrassed if we're humiliated.
So what if you're humiliated?
You know who's not humiliated?
Do you know who's not humiliated?
The people no one knows anything about.
You tell me what's more humiliating than what
happened with Trump.
happened with Clinton.
Tell me.
You tell me what's more humiliating when Ali
said I'm gonna knock out Fraser, and Fraser
knocked him out.
You tell me what's more humiliating than that.
You tell me what's more humiliating than Michael
Jordan when he got the pass and the steal
and Nick Anderson from the pass and he passes
the ball to Scottie Pippen and Scottie Pippen
in the interview, when he makes the comeback
in the playoffs, they lose to Orlando Magic,
in the interview, Scottie says, "Jordan's
never given me the ball.
I couldn't believe it."
He had to go that entire season, everyone
saying Jordan's losses.
You've got to be shameless.
There's got to be a part of you that's got
to be shameless.
You tell your victories through personal stories.
Let me explain.
For instance, let's just say, you know, you
are an alumni from, I don't know, from pick
a school - Yale.
And so you're sitting with a client and say,
you know, it's interesting, I like the fact
that you are a Yankees fan because one of
my good friends who I knew when I went to
Yale together, he was also a big Yankees fan.
And I remember when.
. . Do you see what just happened right there?
Now the client is saying, "Oh wow, you went
to Yale."
But he didn't say, "let me show you my degree
that I went to Yale."
You don't do it that way.
You connect and then you talk about what you
did.
Right?
Self- promotion.
Here's another way.
You know, these are impressive plaques, listen,
one thing I can tell you is for somebody like
yourself who I see here being recognized as
a top attorney, it takes a lot of work to
get that.
I respect that because in our company, when
I got my plaque for the top broker of our
company, I remember the effort it took to
get there, and what's crazy is many times
people don't see the effort behind closed
doors.
So I applaud you for what you did."
Did you see what just happened right there?
There's a linkage of self-promotion.
So there's a way you do it.
I have a friend of mine who's a doctor who
has a hard time talking about the fact that
he's a doctor.
This guy grew up in Inglewood, and everybody
around him was either.
. . the prime time of colors was when this
guy grew up in that area, he comes out of
that mess, he goes to school, becomes a doctor
himself, and he doesn't want to say he's a
doctor because he feels like he's bragging.
There's a way of doing it, where it can be
subtle, through stories.
#2: You're only as good as your last victory.
So let me explain what I mean by this.
If you're talking about your victory from
28 years ago, your Al Bundy.
And if you don't know who Al Bundy is, back
in the day there used to be a show on T.V.,
what was it called?
It was called Married with Children.
And the main star, his name is Al Bundy.
And he would always talk about how he threw
four touchdowns in high school, when they
won the championships, and he was in his fifties.
And everyone said, people who talk about high
school victories, they're Al Bundys.
Don't talk about victories from 22 years ago.
You've got to talk about your most recent
victories.
No one cares about 16 years ago, unless if
you're a grandpa and you're telling your story
to your grandkids, and that was 39 years ago.
If you're in the hunt today, building it and
competing, you've got to talk about your recent
victories that you have.
#3: One of the ways you self-promote is you
build up other people.
That's strange, because a lot of times people
think you self-promote by knocking other people
down, and there may be some conflicting ideas
here because some of these people are experts
at knocking the other people down, right?
You say hey, Ali used to say you look like
a mummy.
He looks like a mummy.
Right, when you hear Ali talk all this smack.
He's the ugliest man I've ever met in my life.
I've never met a man uglier than him, right?
He would say all this type of stuff.
Mayweather would try to do that.
Jordan was very big when he was talking smack
in the game.
But there's an element of you building other
people up while you're building your business.
I remember when we were selling memberships
at Bally Total Fitness and I had just come
to a new club at Bally's and everybody there
was accustomed to selling the memberships
by bashing 24-Hour Fitness.
They would bash 24-Hour-Fitness and I told
everybody, listen, stop.
We're no longer bashing 24-Hour-Fitness.
They said, "Why?"
I said, Let me explain why we're not going
to bash.
Here's what we're going to be doing.
So people would come in and I would say, so
let me ask you, how much do you know about
Bally Total Fitness and what other gyms are
you looking at?
Oh, you know what, I've looked at you guys
and at 24-Hour Fitness.
What do you like about 24-Hour Fitness?
I like the fact that 24-Hour Fitness doesn't
have a contract.
Okay, aside from that, what else is important?
Is distance important to you?
Well yes.
What's closer to your house, Bally Total Fitness
or 24-Hour Fitness?"
They would say, Well I live a block away from
Bally's.
I said, "So how far is 24-Hour-Fitness from
you?"
Nine miles.
How much of a drive does it take in traffic?
About 30 minutes.
How long does it take to come over here?
They would say, "five minutes."
I said, "So that's about 25 minutes difference
going and coming back.
So that's 50 minutes, right?
I said, is 50 minutes times three times a
week that you're planning on coming to the
gym, that's 150 minutes a week, 600 minutes
per month, is that worth more than $5 a month
for you?
And they would say, "Well, you know, it is."
I said, "So you want to go to 24-Hour Fitness.
And you're willing to give up 600 minutes
per month just for $5 less?
Just for no agreement?
Isn't time more important to you than a price
on a down payment of a membership?"
Of course it is.
I said because 24-Hour Fitness is a great
gym.
They have a lot of great things going on.
But I will tell you one thing about why people
join Bally Total Fitness here.
Because we like committed members, because
our members who are close to us, we're located
in a perfect location, we intentionally chose
certain real estate properties because we
want to save time for you, because we want
you to go home and spend time with your kids
and your wife.
That's important to us.
But we still want you to stay in shape.
Does that make sense?"
And boom, we got the contract.
So they'd come on board and the contract.
. . so build other people up.
Sometimes you've got to ask, okay, so, tell
me about the competitors, what you like about
them.
They do a lot of great things.
Let me tell you what we do.
What's more important to you.
. . And then you self-promote your business
based on what the needs are of the client
out there.
#4: Make some predictions.
Make some predictions.
I predict.
. . is going to take place.
Okay.
For instance, I just made a prediction a couple
of days ago on a Twitter video and I told
everybody what my thoughts are on Twitter.
I may be completely wrong.
But I feel based on the research I've done
and the intuition that I have, I feel that
something's going to happen with Twitter and
there's a reason why their valuation went
from being a $40 billion company to today
no one even wants to come pay them a $10 billion
company.
Not Apple, not Salesforce, not Google.
They all were interested at one time, no one
wants to buy them.
So I made my predictions about Twitter.
If you haven't seen the video, you can go
see the video.
The video is titled, Is Twitter the Next Myspace?
Or something like that.
Let's put a link of it or an image of it so
they can see it.
Make some predictions based on your intuition
and based on research.
Why is that important?
Well what if some of your predictions become
a reality?
Okay, then you have credibility.
Because when you say what's going to take
place, it becomes a reality.
Just make sure you're not making things up
based on a nonsense opinion.
Then you're like everybody else.
You can't self-promote that because then you're
decisions are not that accurate.
Now some people may say, What dumb advice,
Pat.
Are you really telling people to make some
predictions?"
Yeah, that's kind of what great real estate
developers do.
That's kind of what great real estate investors
do.
That's kind of what great stockbrokers do.
They say, I think this is what's going to
happen with the market and if you want to
position yourself, I foresee.
. . taking place.
So why not you do it?
Hey, I foresee the economy and the marketplace
going.
. . in this area and I think you need to position
yourself here.
I think you're smart if you do this.
I wrote a book called The Next Perfect Storm
specifically for the life insurance industry.
I'm not recommending you read it, it's for
my industry, the life insurance industry.
I wrote the book with the prediction I made
on what I foresee happening in the marketplace
in the next five, 10, 15, 20 years.
All these insurance companies read it and
they wanted to partner up with us.
Why?
Because they said, this makes sense.
Don't be afraid to make some predictions within
your industry, your own marketplace that you
have going on.
Next, name dropping.
Let me talk about name dropping.
There are ways you do name dropping that is
absolutely annoying and it backfires.
It's absolutely annoying and it backfires.
Let me give you the simplest one.
Don't namedrop if you don't know the person.
Okay.
So for instance, if you say something like,
oh, you know what man, I'm good friends with
Beyoncé.
Oh really?
That's pretty impressive.
Yeah, Beyoncé and I. . . and all you ever
did is you went to a concert and Beyoncé
was there with 30,000 other people, and you
claim you're friends because you're friends
with her on Facebook, because you're a fan
and you follow her on Twitter.
You're not friends, right?
But some people like to say that.
Oh, you know, I got to tell you about this
story with.
. . if you're going to name drop, do it in
a subtle way, but you better validate it.
People have done that to me and once they
couldn't validate it, it completely lost their
credibility.
One of the reasons why I left the former company
is because there was somebody there that kept
name dropping and they never became a reality.
Eventually everybody said this guy's full
of it.
I like credibility.
I like for you to say it and it becomes a
reality.
So now if you do name drop, for instance,
yeah, you know, John, this is a great opportunity
to sit down with you and talk to you.
You know, one of the things I like is that
you kind of remind me of Steinbrenner.
Back in the day I used to work for the Yankees
and when I worked for the Yankees, I moved
up in the company and I started working with
Mr. Steinbrenner and I traveled with him and
his family and it was a great experience,
but you and him have a very similar presence
together and it's great to meet you.
I've heard a lot of good things about you.
[snap] Okay.
There is a connection.
Now if he goes back and finds out that never
happened, you lose the deal.
But if he goes back and finds out that happened,
man, credibility.
Come on in.
What do we need to do?
So you call back, and he's always going to
link you.
No one's ever going to say it, but you call
back, who's calling?
Billy Bob.
Oh, Billy Bob is the Steinbrenner guy.
Bring him in.
So now what if you don't tell that story?
You wasted an opportunity to self-promote.
A good opportunity.
Here's another one how to drop.
Instead of name drop, book drop.
What's book drop?
When you're well read, I've ready quite a
lot of business books, and if I'm sitting
there with a meeting, and somebody says something
in a meeting, and I'll say, you know what,
one of the books I read was such and such,
and in this book it talks about this and I
feel like this is what's going on here with
the company.
And I recommend that book to you.
And you'll see them.
Every time you see them, if they're sharp
they'll go, what's the book's name again?
And you know what?
I remember one time when another topic comes
up, I read a book once called.
. . if you can give two to three book recommendations
in a business conversation with somebody,
in their mind, they're linking you to a self-educated
autodidact.
You don't wait and you constantly try to feed
information to yourself because you're a self-educated
person.
Whether you have a degree or not, it's irrelevant.
In their mind, you're educated.
They're not saying in their mind that you
have a degree.
In their mind they're saying you're educated
and you want knowledge.
So book drop sometimes.
Not just name drop.
Book drop sometimes.
Next, strong opinions about certain subjects
within your field of expertise.
So it's similar to what I said earlier on
making predictions, but this is strong opinions.
It's not necessarily predictions.
You're making opinions.
I don't agree with where the marketplace is
going.
I think one of the mistakes the industry made
was.
. . I think they could have done this better
or they could have done this better.
This even helps if you have your own blog
or your own vlog or your own podcast or your
own whatever you write, where people are seeing
your thoughts.
You know, I wrote this one blog about this
and I can send it to you, you can read it.
And this blog, it created a lot of controversy
because my belief in it was such and such.
For instance, for me, four years ago, I wrote
an article why I don't believe home ownership,
home ownership is not the American dream.
This thing blew up.
Fox contacted me.
CNN contacted me.
Everybody contacted me.
The Denver Post, that I think is the #15 publication
in America did a feature on it.
And they sent me the paper and the frame is
somewhere around here.
I don't know where it is.
It's somewhere around here.
If you go type in Denver Post Bet-David.
And the whole feature was they came, pictures,
all this stuff, this entrepreneur doesn't
believe in home ownership.
That was my opinion.
It created so much controversy just because
I did one video on YouTube saying why, what
the real American dream is, and I said it's
not home ownership.
It's entrepreneurship, right?
Created a lot of debate.
Share your thoughts.
Share your opinions.
And self-promote those articles that you've
written.
Next, have a certain level of certainty on
what you're talking about.
People will know the difference between certainty
and somebody who's not certain.
Believe me, it's not that hard to know when
somebody is certain about what they're talking
about.
Initially when we started doing channels,
people would say, Pat, do you read a teleprompter?
Do you have a teleprompter that you go through?
I don't have teleprompters.
I can't speak about these things with you
if it's not fresh here [mind], because I can
store these episodes in my brain and remember
everything I'm telling you.
Just like people can tell if you know what
you're talking about with a level of certainty,
if you're feeding this thing [mind].
And the more with certainty you talk about,
your certainty alone is a way of self-promoting
yourself.
Your level of certainty is a level of self-promotion
that you're having.
Next one.
To young and new entrepreneurs, a lot of times,
now people will say, Pat, how about if I'm
a young entrepreneur.
How do I self-promote myself if I don't have
any victories?
How about if I don't have anything?
What am I going to self-promote myself when
I'm dealing with some people?
Very simple.
Everybody started off not having anything
to self-promote themselves with, except for
except for the following.
Mr. and Mrs. Jones, there's one thing I could
tell you is, I don't know many people who
are as committed, hard-working, in their trade,
as much as I am.
I can tell you this.
The industry, I'm going to make a lot of positive
impact in people's lives.
I take this thing very, very seriously.
I take my clients' time very, very seriously.
This is why people like doing business with
me.
This means a lot to me.
The fact that you opened your doors to me
means you trust me to come into your office
and present different options to you.
That means a lot to me.
And I don't take that for granted.
That is very important to me.
So I want you to know, I'm very serious and
very dedicated about what I'm doing.
And my plans are in the next 10 years to open
up seven new offices.
My plan's in the next 10 years to be able
to take my client's business from xyz to abc.
My plans in the next five to 10 years is to
be able to do this and I'm hoping you can
be one of those clients I can do this great
work for, with a lot of discipline and dedication.
Hopefully you'll give me the opportunity to
deliver for you.
Certainty.
Commitment.
Where you're going, you better deliver.
If you don't, you are not a self-promoter
that's going places.
You're a bullshitter.
You've got to deliver.
If you keep changing, changing, changing,
changing, changing what you're selling, zero
credibility.
This is why I say choose one thing for 10
years.
Choose one thing for 10 years and stick to
it for 10 years.
So now, do's and don'ts.
Don't overdo it.
It's annoying.
Don't make things up.
I already told you this..
Let me explain what I mean by don't overdo
it.
Ladies.
Think about if if you go on a date with a
guy, who he constantly brags on himself.
And 80% of the time he's talking, 20% of the
time you're talking.
You don't like that.
Who likes that?
No one likes that, right?
There's not a single person that likes, "Let
me tell you who I am.
Oh yeah, you know, I know everybody.
I go to the night club, the bar, the owners
know who I am.
Every time I go I get the table.
They give me the bottle."
You're annoying!
That's not attractive.
That's annoying.
You're hiding an insecurity.
There's something you are not comfortable
about yourself.
Everyone can tell.
Then there's the guy that just says, "Oh great,
yeah, no problem.
Awesome.
Yeah."
But he still self-promotes himself.
Here's why.
Ladies.
I'm going to talk to you first and gentlemen,
I'm going to talk to you.
Ladies, honestly.
Did you really end up liking a guy who didn't
self-promote himself.
Honestly.
Are you dating a man that somehow someway
didn't self-promote himself.
Come on!
You didn't self-promote yourself?
What do you think makeup is?
Makeup is self-promotion.
What do you think shaving legs is?
What do you think us shaving our goatee is?
What do you think us getting our hair done
is?
That's self-promotion.
What do you think it is to wear cologne?
It's self-promotion.
What do you think it is to work out?
Self-promotion.
What do you think it is to take care of our
bodies?
Self-promotion.
How about shoes?
When my wife and I were dating, and we went
through the process of fighting, it was after
about - you know, the first six months, everyone
bullshits.
It's not a real relationship.
It's fake.
The first six months is fake.
It's Hollywood.
It's not real.
Don't believe it.
Everyone lies in the first six months.
I love you so much, here's a dozen roses.
And then nine months later, what dozen roses,
man?
Oh, I love you, the toes are always perfectly
done.
Every time.
Like they get their toes done every day.
Eight months later, what happens?
There are cracks on the toes.
What happened?
Self- promotion.
Self-promotion is gone.
The reality sets in.
Oh, I didn't get a chance to get my toes done
and they're kind of walking and I'm like,
oh my gosh!
What happened to those toes?
Man, they were nice toes.
Self- promotion is gone, right, a little bit.
Watch this.
Stay with me here.
My wife and I were together for about a year.
I hadn't proposed yet.
And we got into a very big fight.
You know what she told me?
She said, "Don't you get it!
No woman is ever going to treat you as good
as I'm going to treat you.
No one is.
No woman.
Don't you understand that?"
She said this to me.
Watch when she said this to me.
She said this to me in '08.
She's going to watch this on the video and
she has no clue I even said this.
I'm going to show it to her because she watches
the video.
She has no idea I said this.
That had an influence over me proposing to
her.
Think about that.
Even my wife is a self-promoter.
Think about it.
So none of us here are too good to be, and
it's righteous.
. . stop.
The only difference between you and some of
these other bigger guys, they just self-promote
better than you.
And they work harder to be able to deliver.
So my message is very simple to you here.
Go back, watch this video again.
Take some notes.
Make a decision for yourself, what type of
a brand do you want to build.
Are you going to be a brand like these guys
[NY Yankees], that they build a brand where
a guy like me, an entrepreneur is willing
to pay thousands of dollars, thousands of
dollars just to own a seat of the Yankees
where Babe Ruth built, the house that Babe
Ruth built, to give this away as a recognition
for what?
Just because somebody knew how to self-promote
this brand.
And don't be the entrepreneur that doesn't
go and do this, because you will miss out
on so many opportunities if you don't self-promote
yourself.
So let's get this here.
If you've got any questions, thoughts, comment
on the bottom and if you haven't subscribed
to this channel, please do so.
Let me tell you something here about this
channel.
We have a lot of great things we'll be launching
here soon.
This channel is going to be a million subscriber
channel.
Our plan is to get this to a million and many,
many more after that.
I don't believe there's a single channel on
YouTube that talks about the subject of entrepreneurship
better than us.
Yes, I'm self-promoting, but I dare you to
challenge us against anybody else.
No one, there's a lot of guys that keep saying
the same rebuttal, same thing, same thing,
same thing, same thing, same thing, just in
a different way.
But there's no content, no substance.
I take your time seriously.
I go a little bit longer with my videos, because
if I only go for two or three minutes it's
just motivation.
I want to give you value, where you get off
the phone, you take notes, you implement it,
you grow your business.
And I get the messages of people telling me
I was only doing 80 grand last year, my business
is now doing six million dollars per year.
I was only doing $300,000 last year, I'm now
doing $693,000 per year.
Those are the messages I want to hear, but
it only happens if you take this content and
apply it.
So if you haven't subscribed, please do so.
Share this video with some of the people that
need to watch this as well.
And with that being said, [Dennis, good catch],
thanks for watching everybody.
Take care.
Bye bye.